mes premières impressions de la vie sont
très mitigées avec les gitans
quand t'as eu la Palme en peux t'as
laissé à Sarah yevo et tu l'as dit
parce que j'avais un ami et j'y suis
retourné pour l'aider à réparer son mangeur
ouais  était-ce vrai ou était-ce que tu étais timide
ou tu étais prétentieux
étranger
c'est euh parce que la petite maison de production
qui a produit le film ils n'avaient pas
d'argent ouais et je n'aimais pas me battre
avec eux et je suis parti
et c'était très peu de temps  pour
la télévision pour exprimer
mon attitude et mon approche du
problème et j'ai trouvé très vite
que j'étais occupé avec autre chose et
c'était drôle en partie pour les gens
et très sérieusement pris le problème ouais
à propos de moi et des films et de la culture de mon
pays
tu avais à l'époque tu avais beaucoup de
propositions mais tu refusais de travailler
ailleurs qu'en Yougoslavie tu avais
peur de perdre ton âme mon âme et mon
éducation et tout ce que je sais de la vie c'est
et toutes mes langues j'emporte avec moi
avec mes souvenirs  et toutes ces choses
sortent d'une manière ou d'une autre dans les films et j'avais
peur de tous les scripts qu'ils
m'ont proposés que n'importe lequel de ces moments
de ma vie je puisse mettre dans le film
ouais et puis un jour vous écrivez un
magazine un journal appelé Express
politica vous savez tout non non non non
et vous allez bien c'est une histoire de
gitans prenant des enfants et les vendant en
Europe en Europe de l'Ouest et vous avez
alors décidé de faire un film avec ça le premier
signal était très fort
parce que vous savez que c'est comme quelqu'un  qui
a des enfants et tu peux entendre que
quelqu'un te dit que ça me bouleverse
mais ouais quand je commence à penser à un
film que j'ai vu à la première réaction ce
n'est pas assez pour faire un film
et ce que je faisais tout le temps  temps avant
le tournage après le scénario qui est basé
sur l'histoire vraie et pendant le
tournage j'essayais de trouver d'anciens
niveaux culturels de la vie des Gitans
oui et puis vous êtes un ami très proche
du contremaître de Milos et il montrera
le scénario à  David Putnam et vous
savez et c'est que j'ai eu
beaucoup de chance avec tous mes films à la fin ouais parce
qu'alors c'était bien David Putnam
juste après que je t'ai donné l'argent il
m'a donné l'argent et les trois jours après que j'ai
commencé à tourner il  tu as quitté la Colombie quand
tu étais plus jeune tu vivais à Sarajevo
tu jouais au football tu étais assez célèbre
maintenant pas mais très célèbre mais j'ai joué
comme tu connais tout le monde dans mon pays
s'il veut être reconnaissable des
filles et de tout le monde doit
jouer au football  ou quelque chose comme ça
parce que c'est et j'essayais de faire ça
et tu jouais du rock and roll aussi je suis
ouais je joue toujours avec mes
amis avec qui tu as un groupe très célèbre
appelé non fumeur non fumeur ouais
mais ce n'est pas  sain c'est c'est et tu
joues ouais comme Clash il y a ouais genre
de musique ouais Post Punk et toi tu
continues toujours à jouer avec ce groupe et
parfois parce que maintenant j'habite aux
états donc c'est pas possible quand tu es
jeune tu étais très proche de  les chambres
vous vous avez vécu très près d'
eux non ouais j'étais j'étais j'étais j'ai grandi dans
le quartier où
vit Gypsy à manches longues habité à Sarajevo
et donc mes premières impressions de la vie
sont très mitigées avec le avec  l'
expérience des gitans c'est très curieux parce que
c'est un peuple qui vient d'Inde et
ils ont survécu 1 000 ici
dans un autre pays
dans différents pays et cela signifie
qu'ils sont très forts et cela explique
peut-être l'importance de la culture
et de leurs rêves aussi ouais  le le le ce
que j'essayais de ne pas expliquer
mais de trouver pendant le tournage à quel point
toute cette civilisation survit au
temps qui est euh complètement contre eux
et j'ai trouvé que les rêves sont le
contexte historique de la
société égyptienne
donc ils  vivre entre les rêves et et
la réalité qui est euh et ton film
le montre très très bien
ouais c'est juste des gens parce que tu
dis quand il y a deux pièces dans la
rue une mère et une plume et c'est une
histoire et un gosse tombe dans la boue  ils disent est-ce que
nous le nettoyons ou en faisons un autre c'est
vrai ouais c'est une blague mais
c'est très vrai c'est très vrai mais
ça vient d'un autre genre
de pensée parce qu'ils sont
des nomades vous savez qu'ils bougent tout le temps
ils  apporté euh plusieurs types
de
formations différentes dans mon pays dans tous
ces domaines, mais ils ont dans le
sang qu'ils souhaitent simplement déménager tout
le temps pour changer de lieu et euh
la chose qu'ils sont des gens anti-industriels
are  t'as pas peur de donner une
très mauvaise
image des chambres parce que c'est encore
des enfants ils les vendent à l'étranger ils se
prostituent
comment ont-ils réagi quand ils ont vu le
film que tu as fait sur eux ils étaient très
ils étaient très euh tu sais
mis en place pour le film, ils pleuraient et
je pense que ce film a été montré en
Yougoslavie à environ 2 millions deux
millions de personnes ont vu un film ouais ouais
et tous les gitans ouais ils je pense que nous
avons
environ un demi-million près de 700
000 gitans qui vivent là-bas
et ils  étaient différentes
réactions différentes mais principalement ils ont aimé
à cause de la musique et à cause des
rêves à cause de l'imagination et tout ce que
vous pouvez trouver, c'est qu'ils ont honte de ce qu'ils
font.
J'enseigne le cinéma directement, mais pourquoi ne vivez-vous pas
en Yougoslavie maintenant que cela
change,
ce sont les mêmes raisons pour lesquelles les gitans
se déplacent d'un endroit à l'autre où je
trouvais un peu ennuyeux de
vivre pour continuer à vivre dans
cette année à Sarajevo parce que je pense que
j'ai fait des films sur la Syrie et mon
environnement et maintenant ce que je dois faire
et ce que j'essaie de faire, c'est de trouver un
endroit où
je peux trouver un nouveau drame par exemple que j'ai
trouvé quand je suis venu  à New York
immédiatement, j'ai découvert que ce que je devais
faire à New York à Brighton Beach,
c'était le crime et la punition par l'État,
mais aujourd'hui ouais à Manhattan parce que je
pense que c'est le seul endroit au monde où
vous pouvez jouer à Crime et châtiment comme  une
fête vous voulez une vie temporaire vous voulez
qu'elle soit jouée par des Slaves ouais
il y a un grand nombre de
population russe dans le sud de Brooklyn
Coney Island
et j'aimerais prendre un
niveau criminel de l'histoire et mettre dans le le
le  la nouvelle toute nouvelle histoire
sur Roscoe Nico mais qui vit
aujourd'hui en tant qu'immigrant russe aux États-Unis
[Musique]
Je vais avoir 35 ans à la fin du
mois pensez-vous que vous êtes un génie ou
quelque chose de pas
bleu